si l excès qui a 10 ans aujourd'hui à
qui a 10 à charge de personnes qui
célèbre ses 10 ans et des années de vie
de vidéos de youtube on souffle donc ses
dix bougies sur un phénomène qui est
devenue mondiale virale pourrait-on dire
également commençons avec la toute
première vidéo qui était mise en ligne
il ya dix ans aujourd'hui 23 avril donc
2005 par ce jeune homme il est dans un
zoo et y arriviez d' absolument
extraordinaire là dedans rien qui se
passe de drôles de cocasses ou de
tragique
lui il est un des trois employés de
paypal qui a créé cette plateforme de
partage de vidéos ça a été racheté par
une scène compagnie appelée google vous
connaissez et bien la suite on va voir
ce que ça donnait ensuite s'adonner ceci
c'est à dire si le troisième le
troisième site web le plus visité au
monde après google qui a profité de
youtube et facebook de mark zuckerberg
et ça donne et ceci en chiffres on va le
voir à l'instinct à l'instant même un
milliard d'utilisateurs uniques par mois
chaque minute imaginer 300 heures de
vidéo sont téléverser 300 heures à
chaque minute
50% des visionnements se font via paris
mobile si andino sur les habitudes si on
veut des internautes des utilisateurs de
tout ce b est ce que ça donne mais c'est
plusieurs vidéos oui beaucoup de bébés
beaucoup de chats beaucoup d'insolite
mais aussi des moments historiques
toutes sortes de choses
ceci est utilisé comme outil également
de propagande
bref il y en a pour tous les goûts vous
le savez et il ya des carrières qui ont
commencé comme ça on n'a qu'à penser à
justin bieber filmé par sa mère dans son
salon et on connaît la suite
ghannam stahl bla bla bla j'en passe et
j'en passe et j'en passe bref il y en a
qui tire des revenus de tout ça c'est le
cas on va le voir ici de cette jeune
femme cynthia dubé que nos collègues
pascarel seul julien et thomas gerber
ont rencontré à 23 ans en 2010 elle sort
du collège lasalle commence à donner des
conseils de maquillage jeux boites de
beauté sur internet sur youtube
résultats mais elle a désormais trois
cent quarante mille suiveux si on veut
et donc avec des vidéos visionnées
jusqu'à 40
millions de fois et attire tous ses
revenus des redevances donc issues de
youtube justement parlons de ses
salariés de youtube en quelques chiffres
1 million de personnes d'internautes
tirent leurs revenus de youtube 1000
internautes ont des revenus supérieurs à
100 mille dinars 1 milliards ont été
versés par youtube en redevances donc à
ses utilisateurs comme un sage un peu
plus obscurs quoi qu'il en soit voyons
ce qu'a fait un avocat de montréal il a
mis en ligne une vidéo d'un écureuil qui
s'empare de sa caméra gopro savants ou
dans un angle le mans ils sont food
comme le nom à la caméra ce qui
l'intéressé c'est ce qu'il y avait
dessus un petit bout de pain qu'ils
étaient attachés et ben ça s'était vu
six millions de fois et cet avocat de
montréal de wesmount ce qu'il a décidé
de faire c'est passé par le truchement
d'une entreprise qui se charge donc de
gérer si on veut sa vidéo pour avoir un
accès plus sûr si on veut à ses revenus
voilà pour sabella des situations
malheureuses parlons de ghyslain raza ce
stark et d'un trifluviens qui s'était
filmé dans son école amie main les
mouvements des jedi de la guerre des
étoiles
eh ben ils étaient victimes de bowling à
l'échelle mondiale il était ridiculisé
comme quoi il ya des dérapages possibles
youtube en terminant c'est aussi un
outil si on veut de conscientisation
politique on va voir les images de la
place taksim en 2013 en turquie on s'en
sert dans certains mouvements populaires
citoyens pour donc sensibiliser les gens
résultats b you tube est souvent
interdite ou lac s'est rendu c'est le
voyant sur une carte en terminant les
endroits dans le monde
donc où c'est interdit vous les voyez
c'est surtout ici comme on le voit en
iran il ya un contrôle très très serré
comme on le sait en chine il ya même les
écoles dans un état de la soul australie
qui n'ont pas accès donc à youtube il ya
une mylène façon finalement de bloquer
tout ça de plusieurs nuances 7 à se
contrôler j'ignorais que c'était bloqué
même à certains de ces endroits là mais
oui tout est assez ça peut devenir
inquiétant pour des gouvernements qui
veulent pas nécessairement avoir